- [Instructor] A nutritionist
wants to estimate
the average caloric content
of the burritos at a popular restaurant.
They obtain a random sample of 14 burritos
and measure their caloric content.
Their sample data are roughly symmetric
with a mean of 700 calories
and a standard deviation of 50 calories.
Based on this sample,
which of the following is
a 95% confidence interval
for the mean caloric
content of these burritos?
So, pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
All right, what's going on here?
So, there's a population of burritos here.
There is a mean caloric
content that the nutritionist
wants to figure out but doesn't know
the true population parameter
here, the population mean
and so, the take a sample of 14 burritos
and they calculate some sample statistics.
They calculate the sample mean
which is 700,
they also calculate the
sample standard deviation
which is equal to 50
and they want to use this data
to construct a 95% confidence interval
and so, our confidence
interval is going to take
the form and we've seen this before,
our sample mean plus or
minus our critical value
times the sample standard deviation
divided by the square root of N.
The reason why we're using a T statistic
is because we don't know
the actual standard
deviation for the population.
If we knew the standard
deviation for the population,
we would use that instead of
our sample standard deviation
and if we use that, if we use sigma
which is a population parameter
then we could use a Z
statistic right over here,
we would use a Z distribution
but since we're using this
sample standard deviation,
that's why we're using a T statistic
but now let's do that.
So, what is this going to be?
So, our sample mean is 700,
they tell us that, so it's going to be 700
plus or minus,
so what would be our critical value
for a 95% confidence interval?
Well, we will just get out our T table
and with the T table, remember,
you have to care about degrees of freedom
and if our sample size is 14,
then that means you take 14 minus one,
so degrees of freedom is N minus one,
so that's gonna be 14 minus one
is equal to 13.
So, we have 13 degrees of freedom
that we have to keep in mind
when we look at our T table,
so let's look at our T table,
so 95% confidence interval
and 13 degrees of freedom,
so degrees of freedom right over here,
so we have 13 degrees of freedom,
so that is this row right over here
and if we want a 95% confidence level,
then that means our tail probability,
remember, if our distribution,
let me see, I'll draw it really small,
a little small distribution
right over here,
so if you want 95% of
the area in the middle,
that means you have five
percent not shaded in
and that's evenly divided on each side,
so that means you have
two and a half percent
at the tails, two and a half percent,
so what you want to look for
is the tail probability
of two and a half percent.
So, that is this right over here, .025,
that two and a half percent
and so, there you go,
that is our critical value, 2.160.
So, this part right over here,
so this is going to be two,
let me do that in a darker color,
this is going to be 2.160
times what's our sample
standard deviation?
It's 50 over the square root of N,
square root of 14,
so all of our choices have the 700 there,
so we just need to figure out
what our margin of error, this part of it
and we could use a calculator for that.
Okay, 2.16, ic an write a zero there,
it doesn't really matter,
times 50
divided by the square root of 14,
we get a little bit of a drum
roll here I think, 28.86.
So, this part right over here
is approximately 28.86.
That's our margin of error
and we see out of all
of these choices here
if we round to the nearest 10th
that would be 28.9,
so this is approximately 28.9
which is this choice right over here.
This was an awfully close one.
I guess they're trying to make sure
that we're looking at enough digits.
So, there we have it.
We have established our
95% confidence interval.
Now, one thing that we
should keep in mind is
is this a valid confidence interval?
Did we meet our conditions for
a valid confidence interval?
And here we have to think well,
did we take a random sample
and they tell us that they
obtained a random sample
of 14 burritos, so we check that one.
Is the sampling
distribution roughly normal?
Well, if you take over 30 samples
then it would be but here we only took 14
but they do tell us that the sample data
is roughly symmetric
and so, if it's roughly symmetric
and it has no significant outliers,
then this is reasonable
that you can assume
that it is roughly normal
and then the last condition
is the independence condition
and here if we aren't
sampling with replacement
and it doesn't look like we are,
if we're not sampling with replacement,
this has to be less than 10%
of the population of burritos
and we're assuming that
there's going to be
more than 140 burritos
that this popular restaurant makes.
So, I think we can meet the
independence condition as well,
so assuming that you feel
good about constructing
a confidence interval,
this is the one that you
would actually construct.